ايه ده انا اعزائي المشاهدين المنظور
الاوسع لهذه الانتخابات هي انها صراع
جمهوري ديمقراطي على من ستكون له الغلبه
في واشنطن لكن في سبيل هذا الهدف الذي
يسعى اليه ساسه واشنطن يبدو ان المصوتين
لا يهتمون كثيرا بلون الحزب اثناء تصويطهم
بل يهتمون بشخصيه المرشح ففي هذه
الانتخابات لا نشهد موجه شعبيه عامه
معارضه للديمقراطيين او موجه شعبيه مؤيده
لجمهوريه
فيمكن التحدث عن موجه حمراء او زرقاء اذا
كان حزب يتفوق على الاخر باكثر من اربع
نقاط مئويه في استطلاعات الراي لكن
لاستطاعات في السباقات الانتخابيه الحاسمه
لا تمنح اي حزب تفوقا على الحزب الاخر
باكثر من اثنين في المئه وتترجح هذه النسب
منذ اسابيع
لنضرب مثالا على ذلك في ولايه بنسلفانيا
يتنافسوا على منصب الحاكم
الديمقراطيرو مقابل الجمهوري المدعوم من
ترامب دوج مستريان
ويتفوق الديمقراطيه على الجمهوري باكثر من
عشر نقاط او 10% في استطلاعات الراي اي ان
المقعد ديمقراطي بشكل مؤقتا لكن اذا نظرنا
الى منصب عضو مجلس الشيوخ فيتنافس على
المنصب الديمقراطي جون فجر مان والجمهوري
المدعوم من ترامب
والهامش بينهما في استطلاعات الرئيسيه اقل
من واحد بالمئه
اذا التصويت ليس حسبيا بل على شخصيه
المرشح كان فاتر من متقدما في استطلاعات
الراي لكن مع ظهوره وهو يعاني اثناء
الحديث بسبب اصابته بجلطه دماغيه قبل خمسه
اشهر
تراجعت حظوضه اي اننا نشهد نفسا الناخب في
بنسلفانيا يصوت لحاكم ديمقراطي ويصوت في
نفس الوقت لعضو مجلس شيوخ جمهوري يدعمه
الرئيس السابق
[موسيقى]
سبورت
اهالي
[موسيقى]
يا وليد
[تصفيق]